Caption: it's begun Michelle telling us about
Caption: small steps you can take to increase in
Caption: the day and I was tempted to stop for a
Caption: little nap myself luckily I picked up
Caption: with the coffee cart and when you stress
Caption: that we should thank our sponsors
Caption: because we can keep the conference at
Caption: $50.00 if it weren't for them so and if
Caption: any of you work for companies that have
Caption: buckets full of water do keep in mind
Caption: there are always tremendous check
Caption: technical events that you could be
Caption: sponsoring in this town okay so my name
Caption: is Michelle Sanford
Caption: I am a TEDx speaker a tech girl
Caption: superhero the chairman of the Australian
Caption: Computer Society in w-a and I am the
Caption: number one social seller for Microsoft
Caption: in the world yes that is when you cheer
Caption: so I had we have this new sort of
Caption: subtitling thing going on in tests and I
Caption: had been practicing with that yesterday
Caption: and I did encouraged all the other
Caption: speakers to use it however I took that
Caption: back yesterday because everything I said
Caption: it gave me dirty dirty subtitles
Caption: and so when I said I was the number one
Caption: social seller in the world it said I was
Caption: the number one sexual seller and it said
Caption: something well I'll tell you when I get
Caption: to that slide but it was all very
Caption: embarrassing and I thought I can't be
Caption: having can't be having this on the
Caption: Internet it's bad enough anyway on your
Caption: phones if you have the LinkedIn app and
Caption: you click on the little networking icon
Caption: you should see a sort of bar Cody no not
Caption: a bar code anything forget the bar code
Caption: just in the little networking thing
Caption: there's a fine nearby icon if you would
Caption: click on that now then you would see
Caption: everyone in the room that also clicked
Caption: on that icon and you would be able to
Caption: connect to all of those people right now
Caption: it will not stay on forever so you can't
Caption: continue to stalk people throughout the
Caption: rest of their lives but you could
Caption: connect to the people that are
Caption: like-minded people to you if you turn
Caption: that on now oh you can use the bar code
Caption: your scanner thing which is also within
Caption: the networking part to connect to me
Caption: just want to remind you all about speak
Caption: plays bingo which is what I was just
Caption: doing it's quite fun if you take
Caption: pictures of speakers in their various
Caption: poses and then tweet them and I do have
Caption: a bag full of prizes that I don't want
Caption: to take home with me today and so far
Caption: it's pretty much even price that's gonna
Caption: be getting the prize okay so this was
Caption: the other slide that gave me a damn
Caption: embarrassing subtitle because somehow it
Caption: said that I loved last Clint and that I
Caption: was going to smother him in his sleep
Caption: that was what the subtitles came up as I
Caption: don't want to say anything like that
Caption: about Laz
Caption: what I was gonna say it was a couple of
Caption: years ago Lars did the luck note for
Caption: didi deep earth and I was so moved by it
Caption: it was a really personal Lucknow was
Caption: anyone here for that yeah it was it was
Caption: a really really personal Lucknow and I
Caption: just thought how is this gonna go over
Caption: with a roomful of developers who surely
Caption: or they are interested in as the code
Caption: and know everyone in the wind just
Caption: opened up and just shared stuff
Caption: themselves and so it's really great what
Caption: is Lucknow twas about though was
Caption: thinking about what you want to do of
Caption: your life where you want to be in five
Caption: years time and you know the kind of job
Caption: that you want to have and he had looked
Caption: at his life and he said you know why I
Caption: won the lottery what I would do is go
Caption: and live on my farm raise an army of
Caption: robots play with hololens and just tour
Caption: the world and it occurred to him that in
Caption: fact he didn't need to win the lottery
Caption: to do that he could just do that right
Caption: now and there were you know there are
Caption: things that you can do in order to
Caption: enable the kind of life that you want
Caption: and so he just started doing it and as I
Caption: was listening to him give this look
Caption: notes I thought that is so true I could
Caption: do that to have the hashtag is be like
Caption: Lars if you can follow the life that
Caption: Lars lives and and so that's what this
Caption: is kind of about how you can set
Caption: yourself up how you can position
Caption: yourself in the market to do whatever
Caption: you want to do without too much extra
Caption: effort from your day job so when you are
Caption: trying to choose what you want to do
Caption: with your life you have a couple of ways
Caption: that you can position yourself for that
Caption: and either you want to do what Lars does
Caption: which is just tour the world and talk to
Caption: people and do training courses and
Caption: pretty much you know set his own hours
Caption: or you could maybe work for a company
Caption: within industry and there are certain
Caption: companies that you that might look more
Caption: appealing to you than others but the
Caption: only way to really position yourself for
Caption: those is to set your profile
Caption: right let yourself let the market see
Caption: who you are without you having to put
Caption: any extra justification into it so there
Caption: are a lot of free tools that you can use
Caption: to do that
Caption: LinkedIn is obviously just part of it
Caption: any of you that are following me on
Caption: social media know that I use Twitter an
Caption: awful lot especially at conferences and
Caption: events as well if you're wondering how
Caption: I'm number one on the Twitter board
Caption: today that is automation we are in
Caption: technology so you know you don't have to
Caption: do everything manually what I've done
Caption: here is I was reading before I went to
Caption: MDC Oslo a book by uncle Bob Martin
Caption: called clean codes has anyone read that
Caption: book so if you have not read clean code
Caption: I would heartily recommend you read it
Caption: it's a really good book and he lays out
Caption: these principles and he essentially says
Caption: you want your code to be really clear
Caption: you want it to be self-explanatory you
Caption: want people to look at your code and
Caption: just know what it's meant to do without
Caption: any kerfuffle around it so it is with
Caption: your LinkedIn profile it should be
Caption: absolutely 100 percent clear who you are
Caption: from that profile so that you don't have
Caption: to go into an interview and defend
Caption: yourself or you don't have to meet
Caption: people and say hey this is all the
Caption: awesome that I am they should already
Caption: know that in advance they should know it
Caption: from what they can see of you from what
Caption: you're putting out there on the internet
Caption: so I've put a few examples here so the
Caption: first one that's Williams so the biggest
Caption: problem that I have with Williams is
Caption: that blue default banner that is fine
Caption: that is the banner that comes with every
Caption: LinkedIn profile and if you want to look
Caption: exactly the same as everyone else on the
Caption: internet and it's absolutely fine to
Caption: just leave that as plain however if you
Caption: would like to catch someone's eye then
Caption: you could put something else in there
Caption: now you could some people put a nice
Caption: sort of landscape picture in there
Caption: my caching that's beautiful but it
Caption: doesn't do anything to link credibility
Caption: to your brand and it doesn't tell
Caption: anything to tell people who you are
Caption: visually so what Jonathan has done there
Caption: that's the third one he has a chalkboard
Caption: which is filled with technical symbols
Caption: what that says just from that image is
Caption: that he is a teacher and he teaches
Caption: technical stuff so I mean he's not a
Caption: teacher he's obviously he's an architect
Caption: and stuff like that but you can from
Caption: that image have the impression that the
Caption: way he shares his information is by
Caption: teaching and what he teaches is
Caption: technical
Caption: his profile picture is a picture of him
Caption: speaking at a conference so that also
Caption: lends credibility to his brand right off
Caption: and says who is an expert in his field
Caption: what I like about antes which is the
Caption: second one is that is a picture of the
Caption: Redmond campus and in case people didn't
Caption: recognize the Redmond campus she's put a
Caption: little logo in there that says Microsoft
Caption: what that says is this is Antoinette
Caption: Jago and she is backed by the might of
Caption: Microsoft
Caption: she has credibility at her back because
Caption: of that image what Rob is done is what
Caption: most of us speakers have done for this
Caption: conference and he has put I am a speaker
Caption: at dddp a lot of the big conferences
Caption: these days are putting stuff up like
Caption: that giving them to their speakers so
Caption: that they can spread the brand of the
Caption: conference but it also so it lifts the
Caption: credibility of the conference and it
Caption: also lifts the credibility of the
Caption: speaker and it links their credibility
Caption: together what else is interesting is
Caption: that this is the difference between
Caption: using LinkedIn and using CV a CV when it
Caption: hits the desk of a recruiter
Caption: my recruiter's amongst us ran a CV hits
Caption: the desk of a recruiter 200 of them hit
Caption: that desk at the same time they were all
Caption: black and white all times new roman'
Caption: they all have experience they all have
Caption: qualifications what is the
Caption: differentiator there what is it that
Caption: makes your profile stand out from others
Caption: on LinkedIn you have the opportunity to
Caption: do that
Caption: so in Robb's there you can see just
Caption: under his elevator pitch he has three
Caption: images that those are videos videos of
Caption: him speaking at other conferences so if
Caption: you have something which demonstrates
Caption: your expertise maybe it's you giving a
Caption: presentation
Caption: maybe it's an article you've written on
Caption: a website maybe it's even just a photo
Caption: of you another event you can put those
Caption: things in demonstrating what you have
Caption: done what you can do where you have been
Caption: who you have spoken for that kind of
Caption: thing and you can pretty much like your
Caption: whole profile you can attach stuff link
Caption: stuff you can add stuff so that someone
Caption: reading your profile would be able to
Caption: tell very well who you are and what you
Caption: are expert in just by looking at that
Caption: the thing that I really loved most and
Caption: from the start is the recommendations
Caption: because recommendations are essentially
Caption: references in a blockchain what I mean
Caption: by that is you can click on the person
Caption: that has given the recommendation and
Caption: see who has recommended them you can
Caption: then click on who has recommended them
Caption: and see who has recommended them and you
Caption: can follow that chain until you are
Caption: fully reassured that this person is real
Caption: that this reference is real and that
Caption: these people have really worked in all
Caption: of these different places because there
Caption: are absolutely false profiles on the
Caption: internet no doubt about it
Caption: but here you can check you can check you
Caption: can check which is way better than when
Caption: I moved here to Australia if they wanted
Caption: to contact one of my references they
Caption: would have needed to bring Belgium
Caption: they would have needed to ring someone
Caption: either out-of-hours Australian time or
Caption: out of hours Belgium time and speak to
Caption: someone on the end of a foreign phone
Caption: number in a language which is not their
Caption: first language and but what how could
Caption: they check that you know hello is this
Caption: the president of IBM Oh its mission I
Caption: mean yes it is the president of IBM yes
Caption: you know the phone call even the email
Caption: these things are easily faked these days
Caption: but the recommendations I have more than
Caption: fifty of those on my profile now and
Caption: those are from people I have worked for
Caption: people have worked with people who were
Caption: clients of mine customers people that
Caption: were vendors people that were partners
Caption: people that were colleagues and people
Caption: that are friends and by the time you
Caption: read through all of those
Caption: recommendations you have a very clear
Caption: idea of who I am and what it's like to
Caption: work with me which is essentially what
Caption: people are looking for when they are
Caption: trying to decide whether you are the
Caption: person they want to give the job to what
Caption: you were like to work with and whether
Caption: you would fit into their team now people
Caption: seeing me on social media will often be
Caption: asking themselves how many hours a day I
Caption: am on there because surely it must be a
Caption: lot you only need to spend fifteen
Caption: minutes a day in order to be number one
Caption: in the world and all you need to do is
Caption: walking from your car to your office or
Caption: while you're on the train or sometimes
Caption: when I'm walking from my office up the
Caption: road to other customers I will be
Caption: scrolling through my LinkedIn or my
Caption: Twitter and I will just be liking a few
Caption: things commenting on a few things and I
Caption: will make one post in the day when I say
Caption: commenting on a few things you want to
Caption: comment specifically on posts that will
Caption: link you to a field that you are working
Caption: in or a field that you're interested in
Caption: so I did a whole month where I did
Caption: nothing but share posts around DevOps
Caption: and that's because I was learning about
Caption: DevOps and what I learned
Caption: I shared at the end of that month ratify
Caption: then asked me to come and speak at a
Caption: customer presentation with them on their
Caption: box because you have linked your name to
Caption: the expertise of the topic that you were
Caption: talking about and they don't think that
Caption: I am as expert as the people that wrote
Caption: those articles they just know that I
Caption: understand the story around it because I
Caption: have been sharing those articles and
Caption: they know exactly how much I know
Caption: because I've openly shared it oh the
Caption: thing about the one poster day though so
Caption: the one post that is yours in every day
Caption: there is something something that
Caption: happens to you that you learn or that
Caption: you see and you think wow you think this
Caption: is good this is interesting that one
Caption: thing take a picture of that one thing
Caption: and just share a paragraph saying what
Caption: happened to you or why that was good or
Caption: what that was because that thing that is
Caption: the thing that engages interests people
Caption: are not so interested in you just
Caption: sharing Microsoft or AWS or you know any
Caption: other article they are interested in
Caption: what is your personal spin on on what on
Caption: what you have learned on what you have
Caption: seen on what you have done you have to
Caption: put some of that you have to put some of
Caption: yourself out there and be authentic
Caption: otherwise it's not interesting to people
Caption: now the interesting thing about being
Caption: the number one social seller in the
Caption: world for Microsoft is not just that we
Caption: are living here in Perth the most most
Caption: isolated city in the world and that we
Caption: are tiny little city on the edge of the
Caption: world the most interesting thing about
Caption: that is that I'm not super famous I mean
Caption: in in Perth obviously we all know each
Caption: other don't we but to the rest of the
Caption: world who are we we are nothing right
Caption: and about social media social media
Caption: knocks down those walls and it takes
Caption: away the distance between us and it also
Caption: means
Caption: that we are all part of something
Caption: something greater than ourselves so when
Caption: I became number one for Microsoft in
Caption: Australia I had 2,000 followers and I
Caption: asked the guy who was the number one in
Caption: the world the number one person in the
Caption: world for Microsoft was called Fabio
Caption: he's Italian you might guess and Fabio
Caption: had 20,000 followers and I just thought
Caption: well I have 2,000 he has 20,000 I'm not
Caption: gonna be able to be number one in the
Caption: world I'm you know I should just be
Caption: happy with being number one in Australia
Caption: however I looked at what Fabio was doing
Caption: the liking the commenting the sharing
Caption: the posting and I just thought that's
Caption: not so hard I could do that I could
Caption: easily do that and I started doing that
Caption: exactly what he was doing and I became
Caption: number one in the world now during that
Caption: time I reached 4,000 followers so that
Caption: took me a year to reach 4,000 followers
Caption: and Fabio reached 55 thousand followers
Caption: but I am number one in the world not
Caption: Fabio the reason being it's not about me
Caption: it is about the power of my network it
Caption: is what you my friends bring to me and
Caption: what you will bring to me is your
Caption: networks and so it might be that there
Caption: is someone in this room possibly Donna
Caption: that has a massive network maybe one of
Caption: you has a million followers and I don't
Caption: know about that because when that person
Caption: engages with me and engages with my
Caption: posts my posts hit their network as well
Caption: and so my name spreads not just through
Caption: my network but through the networks of
Caption: all the people that are engaging with me
Caption: and so when you like someone's posts you
Caption: are helping them not just helping
Caption: yourself and when you comment you are
Caption: helping them because you are sharing you
Caption: are sharing to your streams as well but
Caption: both review eyes together that's the
Caption: that's the beauty
Caption: so this was yeah first of all when
Caption: people and when people start using
Caption: social media they're a little bit afraid
Caption: to put themselves out there and they
Caption: think what you know I don't have
Caption: anything to say I don't have anything
Caption: that is smart enough or interesting
Caption: enough or serious enough or credible
Caption: enough or or whatever so that's where
Caption: you start by taking the content that has
Caption: already been professionally written by
Caption: someone like Microsoft or RAC
Caption: or whoever it is and you share that
Caption: thing but you don't just share that
Caption: thing you say what it was that you liked
Caption: about the thing so you know I'm sharing
Caption: this PowerShell article because it
Caption: taught me that there are only three
Caption: things I need to know about how I shall
Caption: just putting that personal spin over the
Caption: top of it will change your engagement on
Caption: that post so if you would just share it
Caption: with no comment at all you will get
Caption: about 20 views if you share it with
Caption: three lines over the top about what you
Caption: found interesting or what you learnt
Caption: then you will get several hundred views
Caption: if you wrote the post yourself about how
Caption: you had gone to ratify events and learn
Caption: all about DevOps from Rob and me and you
Caption: tagged us you named us I mean that and
Caption: you named your head if I you would get
Caption: several thousand views it's not for the
Caption: views it's not because it's not because
Caption: we want to be popular that's not what
Caption: it's about it's about putting your name
Caption: and linking your name to the credibility
Caption: of the field that you wish to be known
Caption: for and putting that in people's
Caption: line-of-sight so that when they are
Caption: thinking we need someone we need a
Caption: DevOps engineer who do we know that
Caption: knows DevOps well Michels names always
Caption: coming up there maybe we should ask her
Caption: and either they're asking me do I want
Caption: the job or they're asking me do I know
Caption: someone who wants the job depending on
Caption: what it is that I've been putting out
Caption: there but I am the person they're coming
Caption: to you because I ever
Caption: it's my name to that field of expertise
Caption: this is a can you tell what this is a
Caption: picture of this this is a picture of me
Caption: taking a picture of Jason holding his
Caption: baby so I I was inspired by did anyone
Caption: see Theresa what's his presentation is
Caption: that yeah yeah so - since I have seen
Caption: Theresa's thing not today obviously I've
Caption: seen her teach another day I just want
Caption: to draw everything so so this is an
Caption: example of things that you do that you
Caption: just take a picture of and you take
Caption: about and then you just move on with
Caption: your day so as I was coming into
Caption: Microsoft one morning I saw Jason and
Caption: standing in reception holding his baby
Caption: and on the phone and I just took a
Caption: picture of him like that beneath the
Caption: Microsoft sign went into the office
Caption: posted that on LinkedIn and said hey I
Caption: think it's really great that at
Caption: Microsoft we can bring our babies to
Caption: work if we need to and you know just
Caption: just work however we want to and that
Caption: post got 37,000 views that the reason it
Caption: got so many views is because he was I
Caption: think because he was frowning in that
Caption: photo so he wasn't standing there posing
Caption: with his beautiful baby beneath the
Caption: Microsoft sign he was standing there
Caption: really working and he was frowning
Caption: because he was actually on the phone to
Caption: a customer and he's trying to answer
Caption: their problem whilst holding a baby
Caption: that's real life and that's real life
Caption: happening and it's insight into what
Caption: it's like to work at your company which
Caption: people always want to see what is it
Caption: like to work at another company and they
Caption: want it to look real and that that was
Caption: real
Caption: there was only one snarky comment that I
Caption: got on that
Caption: and some guy said I don't think that's
Caption: really a good work-life balance he
Caption: should have been able to just take the
Caption: day off and you know take care of his
Caption: baby
Caption: which is interesting well I just said
Caption: hey if you wanted to take the day off
Caption: and spend the day with his baby he could
Caption: do that that's up to him if he wants to
Caption: work from home with his baby he could do
Caption: that that's up to him
Caption: but if he wants to bring his baby in and
Caption: do his job anyway because he can because
Caption: it is a pretty quiet baby she never
Caption: cries then he can totally do that and
Caption: you know that's that's true that's the
Caption: world we live in that is the kind of
Caption: workplace that we live in and that's
Caption: what's interesting to people so you know
Caption: just what you see what you do where you
Caption: go that's what people want to know about
Caption: the other one that was really popular
Caption: was when I went to Redmond and there's a
Caption: bunch of tree houses there that are
Caption: meeting rooms and people love tree
Caption: houses the idea that you could abandon
Caption: your office and sit in a tree and work
Caption: there all day
Caption: that's a wonderful wonderful thing so
Caption: yeah those are the those are the things
Caption: so 38k for Jason and his baby 5k for the
Caption: for the tree houses 19k I got four I
Caption: spoke at a Google conference and I
Caption: forgot to take a picture of myself at
Caption: the Google conference which would have
Caption: been better and so I literally just took
Caption: a picture of myself at my desk when I
Caption: got back and said I forgot to take the
Caption: picture nobody nobody cares that's not
Caption: what interesting what is interesting is
Caption: that you're telling the story about who
Caption: you are where you went what you did and
Caption: what it was like that is interesting to
Caption: people and the other one 13.5 K that was
Caption: when Satya gave every single employee in
Caption: the company a copy of his book and they
Caption: were all annotated
Caption: yeah with all these little scribblings
Caption: and notes that he had made just for us
Caption: so if you want to be a leader you have
Caption: to have followers so when I first
Caption: started stalking Fabio to see what he
Caption: was doing so well I thought he was the
Caption: it's not just that he had 20,000
Caption: followers it's that he was the head of
Caption: the services and consulting business in
Caption: Italy
Caption: so he's the head of a whole division and
Caption: he's writing all of these articles for
Caption: CIOs on CIO thought leadership and I
Caption: just thought wow imagine each of us has
Caption: the power to influence all of the CIOs
Caption: all of the the technical leadership
Caption: within our town by using a tool like
Caption: this by just writing down our ideas and
Caption: those people will read them and of
Caption: course they won't necessarily read them
Caption: if that's not your target audience so
Caption: maybe you're maybe you like to write
Caption: deep technical stuff in which case your
Caption: target audience is developers and then
Caption: hopefully it's developers that are
Caption: reading your staff or people that want
Caption: to become developers but it could be
Caption: that you want to put yourself up there
Caption: as someone who is a thought leader for
Caption: digital or for transformation or for
Caption: CIOs or whatever and so those articles
Caption: that you write those set the tone for
Caption: your profile and you know liking and
Caption: commenting on other similar articles
Caption: also establish you as that person so
Caption: maybe you aren't that person today but
Caption: the more of the Articles that you write
Caption: the more that you learn the more that
Caption: you do it you will become that person by
Caption: the time someone wants to recruit you
Caption: into their business for being that
Caption: person or in that case like laughs maybe
Caption: you don't want to work for anyone's
Caption: business maybe you just want to do it
Caption: for yourself maybe Lars is not a good
Caption: example anymore maybe like Troy hunts I
Caption: say that because laws has taken a job
Caption: for
Caption: yeah yeah but you know that's your it
Caption: should be a choice if you position
Caption: yourself well then you can choose who
Caption: you want to work for and they should
Caption: they should be coming they should be
Caption: coming to you because it should be so
Caption: obvious the good thing is when you first
Caption: start writing articles and you're
Caption: worried that maybe if you write an
Caption: article people are gonna think it's
Caption: stupid and it's not good enough it's not
Caption: worthy or whatever the good thing is
Caption: when you write your first article the
Caption: only person that's going to be reading
Caption: that is your mum your wife or your
Caption: husband maybe actually I don't think my
Caption: husband reads my article so yeah if you
Caption: don't have a lot of followers then no
Caption: one's gonna be seeing your stuff and no
Caption: one's gonna be reading it and so you can
Caption: ride it you can edit it if someone comes
Caption: to you and writes a comment on there
Caption: saying this is really stupid you didn't
Caption: talk about such-and-such you can edit
Caption: that article you can talk about
Caption: such-and-such if you want to and then
Caption: you can say hey I've changed it what do
Caption: you think now and give them a chance to
Caption: you like it if they're still a dick
Caption: about it and you can just delete that
Caption: comment as well so there's literally no
Caption: risk I set myself a target to sort of
Caption: write you know one per week when I had
Caption: no articles and I would think about what
Caption: was the thing that I'd kind of discussed
Caption: with people during the week it tends to
Caption: be that there's something that some
Caption: people's minds you have a conversation
Caption: with someone and then later in the week
Caption: you say oh hey I was just talking about
Caption: that with such-and-such what do you
Caption: think and then you say hey you did you
Caption: have any thoughts on this I was just
Caption: talking about it with this guy earlier
Caption: and as you sort of iterate on that
Caption: conversation over the week by the time
Caption: you've come to the end of the week
Caption: you've got an interesting topic to talk
Caption: about you've got something that you've
Caption: learned Eve iterated on and you
Caption: like and you can sort of write that down
Caption: and that should only take you like 15-20
Caption: minutes I mean you know just like spew
Caption: it out don't think too hard if you think
Caption: too hard then well a colleague of mine
Caption: has an article in draft and it's been in
Caption: draft for a year and a half now
Caption: don't do that just do it publish get it
Caption: out there and write another one next
Caption: week and then another one because then
Caption: you can you can learn what it is you
Caption: care about and you can build that
Caption: expertise so I've written a load of
Caption: articles on building a LinkedIn profile
Caption: so you know build better LinkedIn
Caption: profile LinkedIn 101 LinkedIn 280 I've
Caption: written ones about getting jobs about
Caption: careers I've written ones about getting
Caption: rejected because no matter how great you
Caption: are no matter what if you put yourself
Caption: out there you will be rejected people
Caption: love my articles about rejection because
Caption: it turns out I'm not the only one being
Caption: picked people or get rejected and so if
Caption: you can share something that you have
Caption: learnt from a time that you failed
Caption: that's useful to people I should say
Caption: that during this presentation I am
Caption: tweeting out extra links to extra
Caption: content and also some of the slides and
Caption: stuff like that so if you're following
Caption: on Twitter
Caption: you should see those extra things coming
Caption: out as well do you know what this is
Caption: does anyone recognize what this is meant
Caption: to be Harry Potter's but it has a
Caption: lightning bolt to remind me to talk
Caption: about the electric superhighway that
Caption: travels all the way up the west coast of
Caption: Australia and well what else would it be
Caption: in waa that we have that's magic be
Caption: autonomous buses yes
Caption: so it wasn't actually that far off when
Caption: you said Harry Potter because it is a
Caption: Magic Bus this is our AC Magic Bus
Caption: autonomous bus as I believe people
Caption: formerly call it
Caption: I do call it the Magic Bus all the time
Caption: the reason I mentioned that RA see Magic
Caption: Bus
Caption: is because RAC are one of the companies
Caption: the ease is linked in really well and if
Caption: you follow them as a company you will
Caption: see that everything they post links them
Caption: to innovation links them to community
Caption: links them to good things actually you
Caption: know a bank west also do it
Caption: Congress also do it really well a lot of
Caption: stuff around community and around
Caption: bringing up tech innovation and stuff
Caption: like that so if you have a company or
Caption: you you yourself of company page then
Caption: that's the kind of stuff that's it's
Caption: really easy to do post stuff that your
Caption: company does well for the community or
Caption: around innovation and then you're then
Caption: you can employ empower your employees to
Caption: advocate on your behalf so it's easy for
Caption: me to share stuff about RAC or about
Caption: bank rest because the stuff that they
Caption: share is stuff that I would like to be
Caption: associated with that innovation that
Caption: that helping the community magic
Caption: obviously and then you know if it's easy
Caption: for your employees to share then all of
Caption: that there were some companies that do
Caption: not encourage their employees to post
Caption: anything on social media about their
Caption: company they will say you know it needs
Caption: to go before the lawyers and stuff like
Caption: that this is a whole new world that we
Caption: are in now and if you're in one of those
Caption: companies I feel I feel bad for you
Caption: because you can't have any fun with it
Caption: and your company could be benefiting
Caption: from the enthusiasm that you
Caption: for your marvelous company so I realized
Caption: that I am totally don't know what time
Caption: I'm supposed to finish what time we're
Caption: supposed to finish ten minutes okay cool
Caption: so how many of you would consider
Caption: yourselves an introvert I would think
Caption: that probably the ones that are super
Caption: introverts though didn't raise their
Caption: hands at all and so yeah I I find myself
Caption: very anxious at tech conferences less so
Caption: with this one because we all know each
Caption: other and we're all friends here but
Caption: normally you know it's very it's I get
Caption: very anxious inside the idea that there
Caption: is a whole room of people and you need
Caption: to make friends you need to network and
Caption: otherwise you're kind of wasting half of
Caption: your money at a conference if you
Caption: haven't done that it's really distracted
Caption: them because you just looked like
Caption: someone that mentors me in the u.s. so I
Caption: invented these games to try and help me
Caption: when I went to conferences and what I
Caption: would do is before I go to the
Caption: conference I would take out a load of
Caption: pictures from the one sheet of the
Caption: speakers that I want to meet when I am
Caption: there and then I would put them in a
Caption: collage and then I would say I'm really
Caption: excited to you go to NBC Sydney because
Caption: I can't wait to see the sessions of
Caption: these speakers and then I would tag them
Caption: all in maybe talk about companies as
Caption: well put a nice photo up and then wait a
Caption: little bit then they were generally
Caption: because they are tagged in there they
Caption: would see it so then they would like the
Caption: post then I would send them all
Caption: connection requests saying hey I'm
Caption: really looking forward to seeing you at
Caption: MDC Sydney I hope we can connect they
Caption: will all accept your connection requests
Caption: because you have spooked their session
Caption: and so therefore it
Caption: a form of social currency you have done
Caption: something for them they want to thank
Caption: you for it they don't want to be in your
Caption: debt nobody wants to be in anyone's debt
Caption: so they accept it and then in fact they
Caption: are they they want to now do something
Caption: more for you so that you become in their
Caption: debt yeah let's get a beer or let's get
Caption: a coffee and so when you get to the
Caption: conference instead of having to queue up
Caption: to speak to the speaker you in fact have
Caption: already met them beforehand or after for
Caption: a drink your automates and then if you
Caption: keep in contact with them over Twitter
Caption: during the year maybe just occasionally
Caption: responding to one of their tweets or
Caption: spooking one of their sessions by the
Caption: time you see the next year at the
Caption: conference she really are best mates
Caption: because social media accelerates the
Caption: connection that you make so you only
Caption: need to make that one physical
Caption: connection and then the second time
Caption: you're good whereas in real life if you
Caption: met someone once and then you had
Caption: nothing to tie you to them in the whole
Caption: year in between you saw them at the
Caption: conference again they probably wouldn't
Caption: remember you so it's it's an accelerant
Caption: it's I do it all the time I literally do
Caption: it for every single conference because
Caption: it not just helps me make friends with
Caption: all the other speakers but I can also
Caption: see what attendees are coming sometimes
Caption: as well because they will comment on the
Caption: post saying yeah I'm going to that
Caption: conference - I can't wait or can we meet
Caption: up and it means that I don't have to
Caption: search people out and make friends with
Caption: them people search for me and make
Caption: friends with me which is much less
Caption: upsetting when you are shy that's a hint
Caption: by the way you should come and talk to
Caption: me so that I don't give people a reason
Caption: to accept your connection or to connect
Caption: you and they generally will so a lot of
Caption: people say to me I only accept
Caption: connections from people that I know now
Caption: that was really no point in use
Caption: like that you may as well just be
Caption: walking up and down the terrace shaking
Caption: hands of people and handing out your
Caption: business card old school because then it
Caption: means that your network can only ever be
Caption: people you know and you will never
Caption: receive an offer to work at a company
Caption: that you don't work at because you don't
Caption: have any connections there so you know
Caption: he in order to open up your
Caption: opportunities to the whole wide world
Caption: you need to reach out and you need to
Caption: make connections at those companies you
Caption: want to work at or places in the world
Caption: that you want to work in or with people
Caption: who have a similar career to the one
Caption: that you want so that you can get that
Caption: inspiration that advice and have those
Caption: connections if you give them a reason to
Caption: connect you they absolutely will so all
Caption: you have to say is hey looking forward
Caption: to seeing your session there and DC
Caption: Sydney Donna's got to you know hey I
Caption: really liked meeting you the other night
Caption: at that event or hey and I would really
Caption: like to work for Microsoft one day I
Caption: wonder if I could just connect you for
Caption: you know advice but try not to make it
Caption: too cumbersome just you know make it
Caption: easy for them to say yes if you think
Caption: that posting a lot of stuff on social
Caption: media makes you look big headed
Caption: especially if the aim was to raise your
Caption: profile so that you could attract a
Caption: better job or better offers or whatever
Caption: then think of those other examples that
Caption: I gave you I'm generally raising other
Caption: people up in those posts and I'm
Caption: hitching my credibility to them so in
Caption: those ones where I have the picture of
Caption: all of the speakers I am spooking their
Caption: sessions not me but incidentally my
Caption: credibility is linked to theirs because
Caption: I have I have spooked them and so
Caption: therefore we rise together we always
Caption: together that is the points that you
Caption: don't you don't have to stand that and
Caption: say hey look at me you can say hey look
Caption: at us when I became the chairman of the
Caption: AC
Caption: I didn't put a picture of me saying hey
Caption: I'm the chairman I put a picture of me
Caption: surrounded by my entire branch executive
Caption: committee and said hey this is my new
Caption: branch executive committee these are all
Caption: the people that have been elected to
Caption: serve the Australian Computer Society's
Caption: membership in the year ahead but because
Caption: you know it's it's easier to talk about
Caption: other people and to raise other people
Caption: up than to talk about yourself then you
Caption: don't have to feel embarrassed or shy
Caption: you can you can talk about your team
Caption: around you and you will always together
Caption: so the story that I normally start with
Caption: and I thought I would finish with here
Caption: is the one that made it really obvious
Caption: to me what the value was here so I had
Caption: gone to a big gala dinner for waiter
Caption: it's the waa IT tech awards that ones
Caption: every year I was super super conscious
Caption: that as the vice chair as I was then at
Caption: the ACS and someone who worked for
Caption: Microsoft I needed to really work that
Caption: room there were adding a five to six
Caption: hundred people there and I am they're
Caption: all like you know a lot of high up
Caption: Executive people and I'm really I was
Caption: really anxious really nervous so I
Caption: arrived about an hour early so that I
Caption: could stand on the sidelines and just
Caption: sort of scope out the room and look at
Caption: the people as they were coming in and I
Caption: would see who would probably not eat me
Caption: if I went and approached them so I saw
Caption: someone I need talking to someone I
Caption: didn't know and thought this will be
Caption: fine this will be a soft entry so I went
Caption: over and said hey um hi and he said hey
Caption: Michelle do you know blah blah he is the
Caption: CTO of the department of big government
Caption: things and I respect I just immediately
Caption: started really panicking there because I
Caption: was like oh my god the first one in
Caption: someone really important in government I
Caption: didn't have physical access
Caption: to meet it's really important that I
Caption: make a good impression I have about 20
Caption: seconds now to say something significant
Caption: to him so that he will not forget me and
Caption: all I really want to say is excuse me so
Caption: that I can run away to the bathroom and
Caption: sob however as I was contemplating all
Caption: of these options that I had in my head
Caption: he leaned in and he said hey young
Caption: Michelle Sanford I follow you on
Caption: LinkedIn I love your articles and I was
Caption: just so relieved because I didn't need
Caption: to prove anything to this guy I didn't
Caption: have to say anything impressive he
Caption: already knew who I was he already knew
Caption: what I thought I had established
Caption: credibility from a distance I had been
Caption: able to access all areas of the business
Caption: and I was actually influencing by volume
Caption: because that article had been read by
Caption: thousands of people just like this guy
Caption: and so we were able to skip over the
Caption: awkwardness of that introductory period
Caption: where we're both trying to prove who has
Caption: the biggest deck and go straight to the
Caption: bit where we're just you know having a
Caption: laugh and having a joke and it's such a
Caption: good time at that event because of that
Caption: guy and the realization the social media
Caption: the tools are the answer for all of us
Caption: in technology today
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: you